[موسيقى]
سدوم حسين ونظامه مشغولون
ببذل كل ما في وسعهم لضمان
نجاح المفتشين في العثور على أي
شيء على الإطلاق ليس لديهم أي
دليل على أن
أولئك الذين يختارون العيش في حالة إنكار
قد يجبرون في النهاية على العيش في خوف من
القرار  صنعنا ونحن
ذاهبون لغزو
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] ،
لم يكن من
المفترض أن يذهب النواب أنا والآخرون إلى غابات الذئب ،
وتحدث أمام
الرئيس قائلاً إن
العراق يجب أن نستغل هذا
كفرصة للعراق و
التفت الرئيس إلى مستشارة الأمن القومي
فقالت له من هو نائب
وزير الدفاع وقال حسنًا
أخبره أن يصمت ،
لا أريد أن أسمع عن ذلك بعد الآن
نحن نركز على الكونغرس الأفغاني
تلقيت تعليمات للبحث عن
سفير العراق لدى الأمم المتحدة
لقراءة
نقاط الحديث التالية له ، ثم
أعطوني بعض النقاط الشديدة للغاية
لسفير العراق الذي
قال بشكل أساسي
إذا كنت تفكر حتى في
الاستفادة
من انشغالنا الحالي
مع
أفغانستان ،
يمكنك أن تكون على يقين من أننا سنتخذ إجراءات صارمة للغاية
ضدك ، لقد كانت
رسالة خطيرة للغاية ،
إنها أكتوبر 2001 وهذه
الإدارة تفكر بالفعل
في العراق وبصراحة أعتقد أنها
تبحث عن طرق لإلقاء اللوم على العراق فيما
حدث
في  لقد اتخذ بالفعل قرارًا من قبل
رئيس الولايات المتحدة بوش
بأننا سنغزو
ذلك ، وأعني أن الطريقة التي أقولها بالضبط
أننا لن نغزوها أو
إذا كانت هناك أسلحة دمار شامل
ستغزو
الآن القرار قد اتخذنا
في طريق الغزو أو ما شابه ، كانت وظيفتي أن ألتحق بالفريق
الأول
للاستعداد
لغزو العراق
قريبًا جدًا بحلول
منتصف عام 2002
أه لم يكن لدي أي شك في
أنه كان هناك تخطيط لغزو
أنا أه
ومع ذلك نحن بول وأنا  استمر في محاولة
تجنب الحرب وعاد إلى ذلك
القرار النهائي الذي
أخبرنا به بعض الأشياء ومن بين
الأشياء التي أذهلتني قليلاً
أننا لن نتردد في
تشويه سمعتك
لصالح نزع السلاح ،
كان الأمر بالغ الأهمية ولكن  المعنى
الذي
أدركناه لاحقًا هو أنه إذا لم
تجد الأسلحة وتنقبها ، فسنقوم
بنزع أسلحة العراق ، لأن
الأسلحة الكيماوية ليست مربى البرتقال الخاصة بي ،
فأنت تتبعها ،
لذا يجب أن يكون لديك سجلات لذلك ولكن
بعد ذلك عندما نقوم  أتيت إلى قصر السلام
في إحدى
عمليتي التفتيش هناك ودخلنا
في كل مكان
وفتح المفتشون الثلاجات
وجدوا مربى البرتقال فقط لا
أسلحة كيميائية فقط مربى البرتقال
أم [
تصفيق]
أه
أنا متفحمة لم أكن غاضبًا من دومينيك
ديفيل فيلبين على الإطلاق لم يخبرنا
شيئًا ما لم يكن صحيحًا
بالنسبة لي ،
لم يكن هناك مفاجأة في طريق دومينيك ديفيل
وأعطيته الفضل أنه كان لديه
الشجاعة
ليخبرنا أنه
قال جيدًا إنهم يعتقدون أنك جواسيس جواسيس
من أجلهم
فقط لا تعجبك
تعرف رئيسك في العمل
سكرتير باول
آه حسنًا ، لذا فأنت تخبرني أنه
لا
يمكننا التحدث بعد الآن ، نريد التحدث قال لي العقيد
إننا نريد التحدث ، لكن
وزير الدفاع يخبرنا بذلك  لا أستطيع أن
أدرك أن جزءًا منه ، إن لم يكن
جزءًا كبيرًا منه ، كان يتحدثون
عن سوريا وكانوا يتحدثون عن
العراق وكانوا يتحدثون عن إيران
وكانوا يخططون للحرب لتلك
البلدان ولم يريدونا.
لمعرفة المزيد عن
[الموسيقى]
الأجنبية
[الموسيقى] ،
قال بصراحة عفواً ،
لكن يبدو أنه قال لي حماقة ،
لذا سأذهب إلى
وكالة المخابرات المركزية وأقضي الأيام العديدة القادمة
هناك في مراجعة كل جزء من
المعلومات
لعمل  تأكد من أنه يقف
لصالحنا
عندما خرجت إلى هناك ، لم يكن لدي خبير
استخبارات خبير
استخباراتي لأخبر جورج تينيت بأن
يخدع نفسه أنت تعلم أنك
مخطئ جورج آسف دعني أخبرك لماذا
أنت مخطئ
لذلك فشلت هناك
إذن  خرجت إلى وكالة المخابرات المركزية وعشت
هناك
لمدة ستة أيام وستة ليالٍ ،
تألف فريقي من كاتب خطابات
لين ديفيدسون باري لوهان
كرون ، وهو عضو سابق في
مجلس المخابرات الوطني ،
ورفض جورج في اليوم الأول منحي أي
وصول إلى وكالة المخابرات المركزية  أجهزة الكمبيوتر ،
لذلك اتصلت باري وقلت لباري
أنك ما زلت تحصل على بطاقتك وما زلت تقرأ
فيها ، قال إنني لا أعرف دعنا نرى أنه
جلس في المحطة الطرفية وسجل في البنغو
وكان لا يزال موجودًا ، لذلك
أخبرتك بإصبعك الأوسط للمستأجر و  كنا
على الكمبيوتر ،
لقد
توقف عن الكلام وكانت الغرفة
هادئة للغاية ،
فأنا جالس على يساره والمستأجرين
جالسين على يمينه
وأدار رأسه نحو تينيت
وقال جورج ،
أنت تضمن لي
أن كل شيء في هذا العرض
هو الأفضل.  يمكنك فعل ذلك
ونظر إليه المستأجر وقال
نعم أفعل ثم قال باول حسنًا
لأنك ستكون
ورائي غدًا في الكاميرا
سدوم حسين ونظامه مشغول
ببذل كل ما في وسعه
لضمان نجاح المفتشين في
العثور على أي شيء على الإطلاق
جلست أمامه من على الطاولة
وأتذكر جيدًا أنني
شعرت بتشكيك متزايد حيال ذلك
لأنه لم يكن متطابقًا على الإطلاق مع تجربتنا ،
قمنا بتخطيط ما
أبلغت عنه مصادرنا حول هذه المرافق المتنقلة
هنا ، ترى كل من
الشاحنات وعربات السكك الحديدية مثبتة  المصانع المتنقلة
نعرف كيف تبدو أجهزة التخمير ونعلم
كيف تبدو الخزانات التي تضخ الضواغط
والأجزاء الأخرى
كيف تعرف هذه الأشياء التي أخبرتك
بهذه الأشياء
ولماذا لا يمكننا العثور على أي من
الأشياء نفسها التي نتواجد هنا طوال اليوم  كل يوم
شهرًا بعد شهر بعد شهر على التوالي
بحلول الوقت الذي انتهينا فيه من
مئات المصادر
ولكن لا يمكننا العثور عليها ولكن هناك شيء واحد يمكنني أن
أؤكده لك
هو أنه لم يكن لديه نية لخداع أي شخص
لم تكن هناك نية لخداعه أنه
كان يتصرف ببساطة  بناءً
على
معلومات خاطئة وغير صحيحة ،
يقول إنها وصمة عار في سجله ولن
تختفي أبدًا ، إنه
ليس إديث بيا إذا لم تندم على
ريهانا
إنه نادم
على هذا
التصوير
[موسيقى]
حتى في
فبراير
لم أتمكن من الوقوف وقلت هناك
لا توجد أسلحة يمكنني قول 700
عملية تفتيش ، لذلك لم نعثر على أي شيء وهؤلاء
متخصصون
كان يخشى إيران من أنه
يعتقد أن إيران ستستفيد منه
وهذا ما كان عليه
في هذه الساعة
القوات الأمريكية وقوات التحالف في
المراحل الأولى من العمليات العسكرية
لنزع سلاح العراق لتحرير شعبه
والدفاع عن العالم من خطر جسيم
تكون
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
لذا
[موسيقى]
أنت